former defense secretary jim mattis who
had said he would never
criticize a sitting president is
blasting president trump's call for the
military to dominate the protesters
the retired marine general accused the
president of trying to divide the
country
mr trump fired back on twitter calling
mattis the world's most
overrated general wishehang is at the
white house with more on this story
rija this seems to be a big surprise
from mr mattis good morning to you
good morning gail and good morning to
everybody general mattis left the
administration in 2018 over a policy
disagreement so
it's not surprising that he and
president trump have differing views
but it is extraordinary how much of them
he
publicly shared mattis condemned the
action against protesters near the white
house
and said it sets up a false conflict
between the military and civilians
the current defense secretary is
speaking out as well
i will deploy the united states military
and quickly solve the problem for them
less than 48 hours after president trump
issued that warning this week to cities
and states
defense secretary mark esper directly
contradicted him wednesday
the option to use active duty forces in
a law enforcement role should only be
used as a matter of last resort
and only in the most urgent and dire of
situations
we are not in one of those situations
now administration officials say the
president may invoke the insurrection
act
which could allow him to deploy troops
to areas that have not requested federal
assistance because he believes they need
help controlling protests
i do not support invoking the
insurrection act white house press
secretary kaylee mcaney says the
president
still has confidence in esper if you
lose his confidence in secretary esper
i'm sure you all will be the first to
know
but as of right now he still does as of
right now secretary esper is still
secretary esper
shortly after mr trump's first defense
secretary
general james mattis released a
blistering rebuke of the president
writing donald trump is the first
president in my lifetime
who does not try to unite the american
people does not even pretend to try
instead he tries to divide us less than
a year ago mattis said this
on cbs sunday morning i will not speak
ill
of a sitting president i'm not going to
do it as peaceful protesters packed the
nation's capital for a sixth
day national guard troops and other
police formed a line to keep
demonstrators
farther back from the white house
right now i think the nation needs law
and order we need healing
and all of those things but we need
safety in our cities
secretary esper had decided to send
about 200 troops around washington back
to their home bases
but reversed that decision late
yesterday a defense official tells cbs
news it was because there are still
a lot of people in the streets and still
a chance for things to turn violent
tony right rija thank you very much